عقوبه قصوى بسجن لاربع سنوات قد يواجهها
ترامب اذا ادينا بتهمه جنائيه او قد يدفع
غرامه ولا يسجن واسيناريوهات اخرى تتحدث
عن مصيره لكن كيف وصلت ترامب الى المحاكمه
في عام 2016 اي اثناء ترشحه للانتخابات
اتصلت ممثله الافلام الاباحيه
بوسائل اعلام وعرضت عليها بيع روايتها حول
اقامتها علاقه مع ترامب في 2006 وعندما
علم فريقه بالامر تصرف فورا اذ دفع محاميه
الشخصي مايكل كوهين 230 الف دولار الى
دانييلز لتلتزم الصمت اي حتى لا تفضح
ترامب هذه الاموال كانت حينها لا تخالف
القانون الا ان مداهمه مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي لمنزل كوهين عام 2018 اثناء
تحقيقات خاصه بشان مزاعم تدخل روسيا
بالانتخابات كشفت المستور حيث وجدت سجلات
خاصه كتب فيها ان الاموال التي دفعها
ترامب لمحاميه كوهين كتعويض عما دفعه
لدانييلز كانت رسوما قانونيه وما حصل يرقى
الى مستوى تزوير في سجلات العمل ويعتبر
مخالفه جنائيه في نيويورك وفقا للمدعين
العامين ليس هذا فقط يقول مختصون ان الامر
يخالف قانون الانتخابات وهي تهمه اكثر
خطوره لان محاوله ترامب اخفاء مدفوعاته
لدانييلز كانت بسبب رغبته بان لا يعرف
الناخبون بشان علاقته بها رغم انه ينفي ما
حصل اما عن تاثر مستقبلي السياسي بما يحدث
الان في الواقع لا يوجد اي شيء في القانون
الامريكي يمنع المرشح المودان بارتكاب
جريمه من القيام بحملات الانتخابيه لمنصب
الرئيس والعمل كرئيس حتى من السجن